[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je pense que
les plus belles découvertes se font au
bout de la rue ce que j'aime c'est
découvrir notre beau pays avec des
personnes exceptionnelles et souvent
insolites
alors je vous emmène avec moi cette
semaine c'est à la campagne que je vous
retrouve nous sommes dans les yvelines
au sud-ouest de paris à rambouillet je
vous propose une découverte de la
bergerie nationale
j'ai rendez vous avec julien pour
découvrir ce lieu unique au monde unique
parce qu on y conserve une race de
moutons depuis 1786 le mérinos et notre
visite commence dans le corps de ferme
historique de cette bergerie
[Musique]
julien pourquoi on a eu l'idée de créer
une bergerie nationale ici alors bas
c'est à la base y'a pas d'idée de faire
une ferme dans le domaine de rambouillet
c'est que louis saez ils aiment bien
venir chasser ici donc il va acheter le
domaine pour la chasse silva le le
modeler pour la chasse et il va profiter
en fait de l'agro manie donc les
philosophes de l'époque s'intéresse un
peu à l'élevage pour construire une
ferme d'acclimatation on va aller
chercher des animaux qui viennent un peu
partout en europe pour étudier en fait
leur adaptation au climat français et
voir si on peut les valoriser après dans
l'élevage quoi et pourquoi plus
particulièrement sur l'élevage sur le
mouton bas pour une en simple c'est qu'à
l'époque la france en fait elle est très
mal placé sur le marché un animal en
france donc on importe beaucoup de
produits de l'étranger donc l'objectif
c'est que la france tende vers
l'autonomie pour les animaux voire même
deviennent référence quoi donc là on est
dans le bâtiment historique qu'est ce
qui se passait ici est bien ici c'était
le la zone où on élevé les animaux en
fait donc il y avait quelques vaches
qu'on avait été chercher en suisse
il y avait des buffles d'italie des
chèvres angora on avait été chercher en
turquie quelques chevaux de trait aussi
la basse-cour elle était plutôt de à
l'extérieur
on est dans le symbole de
l'établissement le pigeonnier comment ça
se passe et avait un pigeon par case ça
alors en réalité on pouvait en mettre
jusqu'à 2 en fait l'idée c'est que
c'était ses petits boulin donc c'est le
nom qu'on donne à osny des pigeons on
pouvait mettre jusqu'à un couple par par
petit nid et donc si je me trompe pas il
y en a un petit peu plus de 1000 dons
qu'on pouvait accueillir jusqu'à deux
mille pigeons dans dans cette enceinte
et donc ils étaient utilisés pour
fertiliser comme fertilisant c'est ça
donc les petites fientes que font les
pigeons qu'on appelle le guano qui est
considéré comme le meilleur engrais
naturel qui existe et est récupérée donc
il ya des personnes qui qui travaillent
ici pour récupérer ce bateau qui était
ensuite étalé dans sur les terres du roi
pour pouvoir fertiliser la production de
la ferme
il a été construit quand ce pigeonnier
il a été terminé en 1785
en réalité il a pas beaucoup servi
puisque comme le pigeonnier était
symbole de privilèges à la révolution
ont aboli les privilèges donc ce qui
joignait on estime qu'il faut plus
l'utiliser donc qui en fait il est il
est dans son jus il a quasiment servile
et twonav quoi aujourd'hui les animaux
phare de la bergerie ne sont plus les
pigeons mais les moutons mérinos à
l'époque de louis saez en 1786 des
moutons sont importés d'espagne
aujourd'hui ils sont devenus l'emblème
est le symbole de la période on achète
quand même quasiment 400 à l'espagne
l'idée c'est d'avoir un troupeau qui va
permettre de faire du croisement avec
les races locales à l'époque
là on arrive sous napoléon napoléon à un
projet c'est de d'habiller ses soldats
pour partir dans les pays de l'est est
aussi de pouvoir faire en sorte que la
france puisse se mettre à la hauteur de
l'angleterre sur le marché de la laine
au niveau de l'europe et donc là il ya
un projet c'est que ce mérinos qu'on va
chercher des parts en espagne sous louis
saez on va essayer de le sélectionner
pour garder les plus beaux individus et
crée la race mérinos de rambouillet donc
à la base c'est une mission un peu
utopique finalement qui va réussir à
voir le jour assez rapidement le mérinos
de rambouillet il a une
grande reconnaissance au niveau mondial
puisque une grande partie une grande
majorité des mérinos présent notamment
dans l'hémisphère sud en australie en
nouvelle zélande en argentine ont un
lien de parenté avec le mérinos de
rambouillet alors ces caractéristiques
principales qui font que c'est un
mérinos et qu'on peut pas le confondre
avec arnaud de ces corps déjà la
première chose c'est les cornes
c'est pas le seul signe mais un des
signes de vieillesse sur le mérinos et
notamment la taille de ses cordes
deuxième principe c'est qu'il faut qu'il
y ait plus de 90% du corps recouvert de
l'aisne c'est pour ça qu'il y en a
certains qui ont de la laine plein les
yeux
troisième caractéristique c'est la
densité de l'aisne donc pour se donner
une idée sur un bélier comme celui ci on
a on a environ 6 kg de laine quand on
laisse pousser cette laine pendant un an
d'accord est aussi là ce qu'on voit pas
très bien ce qu'on pourra avoir tout à
l'heure sur des agneaux qui n'ont pas
encore de l'aisne c'est que c'est des
moutons à la peau plissée donc qui dit
plus de peau dit plus de l'aisne donc
c'est pratique donc c'est plus pratique
j'imagine que alors bien sûr alors
l'originalité de ce troupeau mérinos
c'est que il est dans un système qu'on
appelle en reproduction consanguine
contrôler c'est à dire que tous les
individus sont de la même famille
puisque depuis leur arrivée en 1786 on
n'a jamais été chercher de nouveaux
individus et donc on a réussi à remettre
en place un arbre généalogique du
troupeau avec l'inra qui nous aident
pour faire ça et lors de la reproduction
on va choisir un bélier et on va lui
trouver entre huit et douze brebis qui
ont au moins quatre générations d'écart
avec lui pour pas qu'ils soient trop la
priory avec ce système là il n'y a pas
de problème de tares génétiques de
malformations donc l'idée c'est que on
peut on puisse connaître l'origine
exacte des petits qui vont naître on
connaît la mer on connaît le père
exactement pour qu'on puisse l'intégrer
sur l'arbre généalogique pour qu'il
puisse à son tour servira la au maintien
de la race pour les prochaines
faut bien avouer qu'ils sont mignons ces
moutons mérinos
un peu plus loin il va rendre une visite
aux groupes liés aux animaux la future
ligne et des boutons devant bouillie
donc on voit déjà que c'est un petit
bélier on a les cornes qui sortent et
celui ci il est assez représentatif de
la rade parce que on a déjà la policière
au niveau du cou donc c'est ce qui
symbolise le mérinos comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure mais c'est aussi ce qui
fait qu'il est champion c'est à tondre
parce qu'il faut toujours faire en sorte
de tendre la peau quand on va leur
couper la laine quoi et six décennies
motion qui se laissent faire qui ruinent
quel caractère et une technique très
simple chez les moutons il faut le
mettre sur un de ses idées et du coup
les hiboux ce type d'accord donc du coup
ça nous permet de manipuler les animaux
potentiellement leur couper les gens le
parce qu'il faut penser à leur couper
les ongles au mans deux fois par an
peut-être regarder aussi leur dentition
pour voir si tout va bien
brebis pour marc si ce n'est pas trop
lisez faire aussi peut-être des vaccins
des choses comme ça voile et le loup je
te remets à l'eba
là ils sont tout avec leur petit c'est
saint louis avec sa quantité de l'aisne
c'est un animal qui vit assez mal dehors
donc en fait on profite que l'animal
soit à l'intérieur pour que les petits
naissent donc en fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle le décès zone mans c'est à dire
que les brebis et les mâles sont pas
toute l'année ensemble
et lorsqu'on les fait se rencontrer les
chaleurs se déclenche naturellement chez
la femelle donc là la période de lutte
c'est le nom qu'on donne à la période de
reproduction elle a eu lieu au mois
d'août et donc les petits sont nés à
partir du mois de janvier février et
donc du coup on les laisse avec leur
mère au moins trois mois alors y en a
qui sont là sous une petite lampe pour
ils sont tous seuls oui alors cela du
coup c'est qu'on les a mis de côté parce
que les mères avaient soit les pas les
capacités de s'en occuper parce que la
brebis mérinos n'est pas une très grande
productrice de lait donc il suffit
qu'elle fasse des jumeaux et bal aura
beaucoup de mal à s'occuper de jumeaux
donc quand les élèves du coup au biberon
nous mêmes ou alors c'est des brebis
qu'on carrément abandonné leur petit ça
ça arrive voilà l'instinct maternel est
pas présent donc elle les repousse donc
nous l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que tous les agneaux et leur chance et
ceux qui sont ici alors là ce sont des
jeunes bélier qui ont maintenant
quatorze mois et donc c'est les béliers
qui vont intégrer le troupeau de mâles
adultes dès le printemps donc c'est les
futurs reproducteurs de la race mérinos
de rambouillet c'est la nouvelle
génération
exactement
il n'y a pas que des moutons ici il ya
aussi pas mal de poule et surtout des
poules locales et si julien m'emmène les
voir c'est parce que c'est son endroit
préféré ici julien est passionné par le
gallinacé vous avez un poulailler là où
vous avez un petit peu tous donc des
pintades le dindon les dindes quelques
races de poules ornementales et puis on
a aussi une petite partie
sensibilisation ou là on élève des races
locales la commissi la poule de houdan
on a aussi des poules de faverolles et
de menthe
qui sont-ils et le mans 10 yens voilà
qui ont une histoire dans l'élevage mais
aussi quand une histoire dans la
gastronomie française
la poule 2 ou danser le pâté en croûte
façon ou dans donc c'est des choses qui
ont marqué la france pour dans diverses
catégories
donc moi si j'habite dans la région par
exemple autant que je prenne une poule
10 sinon et on peut en allant chercher
ici par exemple que ce soit ici ou il ya
même des associations qui proposent des
listes de delver et donc quitte à avoir
une poule chez soi autant participer à
la conservation des races du coin mais
aussi une fois par an on propose une des
ventes de races locales pour que vous
puissiez le mettre dans votre jardin des
moutons des poules des chevaux des
cochons des vaches des lapins la
bergerie nationale c'est une véritable
ferme qui emploient près 220 personnes
il en faut du monde pour s'occuper des
animaux accueillir le public faire de
l'éducation à l'environnement ou encore
vendre les produits de lanternes dans la
bergerie nationale elle appartient à
l'état c'est son tuteur c'est le
ministère de l'agriculture
mais il faut pas oublier que pour un
établissement qui soit viable et une
idée du sens du coup il faut qu'il ferme
qui fonctionne donc on a vu des moutons
on a aussi des vaches ou là c'est le
système le plus abouti puisque les
vaches sont labellisés en agriculture
biologique c'est à dire que le lait
qu'elle produisait bio on a notre propre
atelier de transformation sur la ferme
donc on fabrique des yaourts et
prochainement des fromages aussi avec le
lait de ses vaches
il est hors temps les mots jouent dans
un circuit de 50 km autour de la ferme
donc ça va être les cantines scolaires
ou la restauration collective
ces yaourts on les trouve également dans
la boutique ici on retrouve tous les
produits de la ferme et des producteurs
locaux
on retrouve surtout la star des lieux la
laine mérinos et la responsable de la
boutique s'était mis l'île là je suis en
train de toucher de la laine qui vient
des moutons potentiellement qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure alors c'est même que la
laine qui vient des moutons vous avez vu
tout à l'heure on revint la mairie de la
laine mérinos de rambouillet uniquement
dans notre boutique
alors donc ici à la fois des écoles
comme des étoles bollaert des plaids et
toutes nos pilotes pour que tous chacun
puisse tricoter ce qu'il en est alors
oui si on peut on peut aussi manger je
vois qu est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
trouve alors là qu'on est dans le
mérinos café donc c'est là où on
accueille tous nos visiteurs
quand ils ont visité on peut manger
boire un petit jus de fruit un petit
chocolat chaud de la ferme et on peut
acheter les produits qu'on fabrique ici
ou alors des producteurs locaux
bah oui donc le lait aussi des vaches on
peut le boire sous forme de chocolat
noir chocolat yaourt aussi qu'on va
parler les yaourts aussi oui on vend nos
yaourts dans la vitrine donc on a
beaucoup de personnes qui en prennent
pour le goûter ou alors qu'il emmène
chez eux parce que il très très bon les
la majorité des personnes est intéressée
par les produits locaux savoir d'où ça
vient
comment c'est fait et que ce soit fait
le plus localement possible c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire pour proposer aux
gens
pour revoir cette émission julien les
poules les moutons rendez vous sur terre
de france pointent tv mais comme vous
vous en doutez à rambouillet il ya plein
de choses à voir
alors je vous donne rendez vous très
vite pour de nouvelles rencontres
[Musique]